on this very historic deal we talked
about how big of this is really going to
be for the global economy how's think of
it is this in your eyes oh this is big
it's it's important no doubt about that
but it's got a long way to go yet it's
they've signed up a deal but we've got
to see text and then it's going to spend
probably quite a noisy up to a year
going around legislatures around all the
different 12 countries so we're not
there yet but it's the biggest thing
since the Uruguay Round I would think
yeah you know this is the biggest tree
till we've seen since the NAFTA
agreement which also faced quite a bit
of opposition at that time how is
Congress particularly going to end the
president going to actually try to
combat some of these critics because
we've seen them lining up from both
sides well it's always difficult a trade
deal like this but basically it can hurt
some specific industries and some
specific workforces but it's likely to
be very positive and a much broader
sense and of course it's going to help
consumers and that's the thing that's
always quite hard to get across but
that's up to legislators to do that yeah
seems like there's a kind of a mixed bag
when it comes to certain sectors of this
trade deal what about the concerns for
American profits i mean we heard from
ford saying that there just needs to be
more regulations when it comes to
currencies because the Japanese
carmakers seem to be benefiting from the
weaker yen should there be more
enforcement on that front not through a
trade agreement like this that was never
going to happen it's not there for
currency control or currency agreement
that should be happening through the IMF
and through the world's FX markets as it
has and of course different companies
are hurt and and helped at various times
in the cycle but this isn't going to
affect it all right well when it comes
to you know the process you know of
other trade deals as well I mean you
mentioned here the complaint or domestic
ratification press for the WTO with this
trade facilitation agreement is
I could at this recent development of
TPP going to help expedite that well I
think what's really been happening is
it's recognized as very difficult to
progress unilaterally outside
multilaterally for the WTO so we've got
this TPP agreement and then amongst East
Asian and some other countries we've
also got the regional comprehensive
economic partnership where there's an
attempt to try and get something signed
by the end of this year and actually in
APEC we don't want to see one going off
as a sort of rich man's club and the
other going off as a developing economy
club we want to see them coming together
so we're doing a study for what might
come after all of this which is free
trade area for Asia and the Pacific so
it's it's an untidy world and that's the
way we've just got to operate but this
will probably give a competitive boost
to some of these other agreements and
possibly the Atlantic TTIP as well Alan
real quickly here you know we talked
about some of the sectors some of the
very thorny issues when you talk about
autos dairy intellectual property which
kind of ended up being some the last
sticking issues in the final hour what
have you heard in terms of the response
from the business community on these
sectors well I mean you know there's
been quite a bit of objection around
some parts of the business community but
we haven't seen the text here so it's
really too early to know what the
responses should be in all of us this
agreement in principle was going to be
big it got us and japan and others
together for the first time in principle
it should also have been a way to start
moving agricultural trade liberalisation
which has just been very slow around the
world I'm not sure it's actually
achieving that and then thirdly these
new generation issues and that's where
we will look at all the text to see if
this is really setting a standard for
the future